her current tester Sacha Kopp says that
you couldn't imagine modern city life
without delivery trucks we all depend on
them every time we receive packages by
mail or need a handyman
the VW Caddy represents a new generation
of these vehicles it all began in 1978
in the US the first generation of the
caddy was based on the VW Rabbit known
in Europe as the Gulf mark one it came
as a flatbed or a van the second
generation had two forms one was
identical to the Seon Inca and the other
was based on SCOTUS falesha pickup VW
took back control of developing the
third generation as a van it was based
on the Gulf Mark five the fourth
generation is more varied and features a
greater range of motor options than ever
before it's made to suit every situation
only the flatbed option has been
discontinued
the Caddy comes in two sizes the large
one is 47 centimeters longer than its
little brother it's capable of
transporting 857 kilos of cargo Robert
using her head of design and VW's
commercial vehicle division tells us
that his customers appreciate the double
wing doors which can be partially opened
in tight spaces but can also be open
wide the idea is to create enough cargo
room for a standard sized European
pallet by contrast Kirzinger says the
passenger model has a classic hatchback
it makes a completely different
aesthetic statement with its wide
panoramic window that extends all the
way to the sides the aerodynamics are
perfect it's a bit sporty the interior
has been radically modified in line with
current design even the passenger model
has plenty of pockets and storage space
sascha points out that the side door is
practical for both tradesmen and
families children can get in the vehicle
without parents having to worry about
them scratching other cars when they
open the door and in addition to all the
storage features there's even a little
table where the kids can do some
drawings in my income the generation 4
model is targeted specifically at young
families the design is more lively than
the utility model using your says the
firm tried to cover a large number of
bases and took account of people's
various lifestyles here VW said let's
put a bit of color in the rim so the
vehicle makes a different impression
it's primed in black then it gets a coat
of red paint and then it's varnished
these sorts of rims are all the rage at
VW at the moment all models of the Caddy
have live axles instead of flat springs
that increases loading capacity although
it's not optimal for a passenger car VW
has made adjustments in the caddie
offers a balanced Drive but it's still a
compromise on the other hand despite the
vehicles height it's very stable and VW
has launched a lot of driver assist
systems
the water phobias folk ma a VW director
of product marketing says that the car
offers both delivery people and families
a safe secure ride there are airbags for
drivers and passengers as well as side
impact airbags VW also offers a curtain
airbag option for families who want to
protect children in the back
multi-collision brakes are standard
there's a front assist system to help
braking and city emergency braking
system that works up to speeds of 30
kilometers an hour there's also an
adaptive cruise control that helps you
cruise along the Autobahn at speeds of
up to 160 kilometers an hour in addition
there's a high beam assist and many
other systems the only thing that's
missing is a blind spot sensor to warn
drivers of dangers they might overlook
that would be a sensible addition the
generation 4 model Caddy with a 1.2
liter 62 kilowatt engine runs for twenty
four thousand four hundred seventy eight
euros in Germany the motor is capable of
taking the Caddy from zero to 100
kilometers an hour and thirteen point
nine seconds
the beach model caddy is built for
thrills there's an all-wheel-drive
option for all Caddy models but it makes
the most sense for the beach which is
the perfect vehicle for getting away
from it all but leave the kids at home
or put them in their own tent otherwise
space can't get tight
the fava kitty Sasha tells us that the
VW Caddy was born as a pure utility
vehicle and served delivery men and
trades people well over the years but
it's now carved out a niche for itself
in the family car market and is
especially popular among large families
VW has taken the vehicle a step further
with the beach version and it's
wonderful tenth option people who want
to get away from everyday family life
can drive out into the country and sleep
out in the open it takes no time at all
to set up the tent so it's time to say
good night
my Nicole aghh
a car Chester on delayed Zimmerman says
he was told he'd be testing a sporty car
with a rear engine he wasn't expecting
this though he says that Renault
believes even a pocket rocket deserves a
rear engine so he's going to check out
the benefits
the ancient sound certainly isn't going
to set a sports car lovers heart racing
with its 52 kilowatts that Twingo crawls
rather than Sprint's from 0 to 100
kilometers an hour taking 14 and a half
seconds but thanks to its optional
start/stop system the Twingo already
meets EU emission norms of 95 grams of
co2 per kilometer which only take effect
in the year 2020
before Tyler Andre says the benefits of
the rear engine and rear-wheel drive are
obvious as they don't have to transfer
power the front wheels can focus solely
on steering reducing the danger of under
steering and the engineers have created
another advantage in doing this it's big
steering angle makes the Twingo easy to
maneuver in city traffic the Twingo can
do a u-turn on the narrowest of streets
giving you the ability to change
directions and will of course you'll
need to keep an eye out for oncoming
traffic
Andre says the high seating position in
the Twingo doesn't make for a sporty
ride but it does produce good visibility
the Twingo rearview mirror is right at
his eye level so he can see right away
what's behind him though in multi lane
traffic gets confusing as the mirror
hangs right in front of his face
inside the Twingo is colorful and
imaginative though it contains lots of
hard plastic there is even a removable
storage bin in front of the gearshift
unfortunately the gear stick isn't very
ergonomic by contrast the climate
control system is quite user friendly
the same can't be said for the radio
Andre says his test model has no
integrated sat-nav it does have a cell
phone holder but it makes it hard to see
and use the buttons behind it put the
phone in landscape mode to use a
navigation app for instance and it
covers all the buttons using another
external sat-nav rather than a phone app
could also be problematic normally you'd
want to attach it here on the front
windshield but the cable would have to
go in the first 12 volt socket here the
Twingo is a colorful little city
runabout for the urban jungle round
daytime running lights are integrated
into the bumpers the trim at the side of
the car sports the model name and the
concept drawing of the Twingo though the
looks of the real car doesn't quite
measure up for 990 euros extra the
Twingo comes as a convertible with a
folding soft top
the one liter engine is located in the
back under the trunk vents let the hot
air escape Andre says the Twingo has 219
liters of volume more than the Opel Adam
but a little less than VW's up the
Twingo could use a bit more space as the
trunk won't close when these three
crates are put in lengthwise he says
making the trunk lid a bit thinner here
could likely solve the problem if I
smile at America that's probably my
shiny shunga loose shift the crates to
the centre of the trunk though and the
lid closes easily as the plastic
reinforcements are much thinner there so
what's Andres verdict on the new Twingo
DeNooyer Finkelman he feels it's a
really great city card it stops in terms
of maneuverability and visibility at
faster speeds he was pleasantly
surprised that unlike front-wheel drive
cars
it was never unstable while braking
Andre wonders whether Renault will bring
out an RS version as he thinks this
Twingo has sporting potential the
legendary muscle car the Ford Mustang
can now be ordered in Germany dealers
already have access to the first edition
of the new Mustang with an optional 310
kilowatt v8 motor or an EcoBoost
four-cylinder one german list prices for
the new edition of the Mustang start at
35,000 euros a new beginning is the
light motif for the new BMW x1 the
design of the new generation is much
more muscular the x1 features the BMW
series - active tourer undercarriage and
front wheel drive is standard that
creates more interior space and even the
smallest X model comes with optional
all-wheel X Drive
mr. Ronnie let's take tells us that the
small SUVs are a big hit in Europe with
a cx3 Mazdas going on the offensive in
the B segment it's a mixture of the
Mazda 2 and the cx-5 and he's going to
find out what the cx-3 can do a major
part of Mazdas efficiency strategy is
its so-called sky active technology
which encompasses motors gears chassis
and the cars bodies all cx3 models came
with a standard start/stop system and
the bigger engine models also have a
standard condenser system for recycling
energy released when braking in terms of
the motor Mazda is bucking the trend of
increasing efficiency by decreasing
cubic capacity Mazda press spokesman
Johan one singer tells us that the car
maker still features high capacity
engines this model has a high
compression 2-liter engine that means
that this engine is more efficient
especially in real driving conditions
than downsized turbo ones and despite
the fact that these are only aspirated
engines they have good linear torque
development so they're really nice to
drive the 2 litre gasoline direct
injection engine comes in an 88 kilowatt
front wheel drive version and a 110
kilowatt all-wheel-drive option we're
testing the more powerful model it goes
from 0 to 100 kilometers an hour in 8.7
seconds and on average consumes just 6.4
liters of fuel per 100 kilometers
our car tipster says the first time he
saw the car he was somewhat skeptical
but once he got in it won him over
it features quality synthetic suede and
leather the sight lines are perfect and
drivers have no problems pulling out of
parking spots or passing other cars like
all Mazda models the exterior of the
cx-3 is inspired by koto design which
focuses on the use of visual energy a
crucial element are the striking lines
the cx-3 also has an extended hood with
a driver's cab move back
the black D pillars give the car a sleek
silhouette
Jochen moon sigue tells us that mazda
offers both front-wheel and all-wheel
drive x' which is not always the case in
this price class the cx-3 has a six gear
automatic transmission and customers can
choose among a broad range of options
last but not least the car has a
brilliant exterior and a minimalist but
high-quality interior that's also not a
given in this price segment the interior
emphasis is clarity and ergonomics
the driver's seat is adjustable for a
variety of needs and the cx-3 offers
loads of leg and shoulder room
the mzd Connect system allows drivers to
use the Internet
it's operated with buttons in the middle
of the console the cx-3 also comes in a
diesel model either with or without
all-wheel drive the starting sticker
price is seventeen thousand nine hundred
ninety euros for the small engine the
gas powered model makes the Mazda cx-3 a
serious competitor for the BMW x1 and
howdy q3 our tester was amazed at how
little fuel it consumed the SKYACTIV
technology features a condensed motor
instead of a turbo engine which means
that the car only burns an average of
six point four liters per 100 kilometers
his conclusion the Mazda cx-3 is a good
b-segment SUV that's sure to find lots
of fans
on the baltic sea island of rügen
classic car expert Christophe Bauer is
driving a lovely old car with a lovely
name
the Borg warred isabella built in 1954
it was the dream child of engineer and
industrialist Carl FW Beauregard
inaudible Christophe Power says today
there are vehicles to suit every niche
from off-road sports cars to four-door
coupe ace but in the 1950s it was a
different story
mid range sedans boasted plenty of room
but offered little driving pleasure so
thank goodness car maker Carl W
Beauregard from Bremen had a heart for
family men who like to put the pedal to
the medal his Isabella was both
family-friendly and fun to drive the
German sports sedan was born at the
start the Isabella experienced some
teething problems but that was little
wonder the entire vehicle was developed
in just ten months
Beauregard was famous for his
authoritarian leadership style and he
alone chose the car's name
he's a headline Cristo says that
kharabagh vard named it Isabella on a
whim when his engineers showed him the
first prototype and asked him what to
call the car he waved his hand and said
tersely what do I care call it as a
Bella Christophe says kudos mr. Bhagwat
a good name for a good car
in the 1950s the isabella was a cut
above the competition in germany in
terms of both looks and technology at
7,000 darks it costs more than a VW
Beetle but less than a Mercedes Ponton
but as far as performance was concerned
the Isabella left both models eating its
dust Christophe says he could go from 0
to 100 kilometers an hour in 25 seconds
and had a top speed of 135 kilometers an
hour that might not sound very
impressive today but in the 50s that
meant it could overtake more than half
the cars on German roads and 1955 Carl
Burghardt went even farther with the
miscibility s with a top speed of 150
kilometers an hour it set the european
standard in its class it's great
suspension made it a real curve hugger
borge vard had already attracted
attention with the Hansa 1500s monocoque
Ponton body back in 1949 its successor
the Isabella was more elegant with its
opulent chrome trim it resembled the
American cars of the 1950's but the
Isabella's curves and refined roofline
also lent it a style all its own
with seat benches in the front and back
the isabella can seat six adults
comfortably that was the secret of the
model success pairing sportiness with a
dash of luxury the reliable
four-cylinder engine with a side mounted
camshaft had already been used to power
the hans of 1500 thanks to its fabulous
suspension the isabella is nimble on
curves only one thing puts a spanner in
the works this stuff says the steering
column gearshift was absolutely
state-of-the-art in the 50s even Porsche
thought about putting the gear shift for
its 356 behind the steering wheel but
ferry Porsche said no thank goodness he
says as this construction really hinders
quick gear changes and sporty driving
but even this little flaw can't spoil
the great package that is the Isabella
over 200,000 Isabella's were sold
between 1952 and 1964 the model was Carl
Borg farts biggest success none of the
other vehicles he produced under the
Borg fart Goliath or Lloyd brands were
as popular
Beliveau Christoph says the Isabella was
Beauregard's greatest triumph
it was Germany's first sporty mid-range
sedan and the dream machine of family
cars
he says the Isabella spawned a whole new
vehicle class making it a true milestone
in automotive history still the car
couldn't save the Beauregard company
plagued by financial troubles political
intrigues and bad planning Germany's
largest privately run car maker was
forced to declare bankruptcy in 1961